[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions
locales vous présente le club des
[Musique]
territoires ave nous pour CEUB
nicolasonjour Nicolas merci d'être avec
nous éitorialiste politique à la tribune
et Pierre jacquem bonjour merci d'être
là aussi rédacteur en chef de on va
parler évidemment d'Emmanuel Macron 2h20
conférence de presse hier a-t-il réussi
son rendez-vous avec la nation vous nous
direz ce que vous en pensez Steve on va
parler d'un point précis avec vous oui
du nouveau ministre de l'Éducation de
Gabriel àal donc c'est Emmanuel Macron
c'est ce que nous disait le sénateur de
tout à l'heure voilà sinon on parlera
aussi de ces annonces annces est- que
c'est des vrais annonces est-ce que
c'est des choses qu'on connaissait déjà
il y a beaucoup de choses qu'on
connaissait déjà quand même voilà on
voit ça tout de suite allez d'abord on
parle de cette conférence de presse à la
Une de vos quotidiens régionaux ce
matin
et l'actualité dans nos région avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale c'est
la conférence de presse et c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui s'affiche en Une de
beaucoup de vos quotidiens régionaux
pour en parler on va aller à poiti on
retrouve Delphine Blanchard journaliste
à La Nouvelle République Delphine
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
et Delphine dans vos pages vous rvenez
bien sûr sur cette conférence de presse
d'Emmanuel Macron évidemment comme tous
les journaux locaux on a suivi la
conférence de presse et notamment nous
ce qui nous a intéressé c'est les pistes
de réflexion et les annonces qu'il a
fait tourner autour de l'éducation
notamment celle de la refonte de la
formation des enseignants un grand
chantier à venir rien de concret pour
l'heure tout cela demande à être précisé
le chef de l'État également expliquer
qu'il fallait reprendre le contrôle de
nos écrans vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure et que sur la base d'expertise
des orientations pour les usages en
famille ou à l'école seront là encore
annoncés ultérieurement parlant même de
de restriction voire d'interdiction nous
sommes donc curieux de voir quel sera
les les les choses plus concrètes il a
aussi confirmé que l'instruction civique
sera refondée à la rentrée prochaine
appuyé sur les textes fondateurs de la
nation et si l'expérimentation de la
tenue unique qui sera menée dans une
centaine d'établissements volontaires
comme àmoge est concluante elle pourra
aussi être généralisée à la rentrée
prochaine ça risque là encore de faire
grincer des dents du côté de C
enseignants autre nouveauté Emmanuel
Macron assure qu'il veut faire du
théâtre en plus du sport et de l'accès à
la culture pour tous un passage obligé
au collège dès la rentrée prochaine cela
permet selon lui d'apprendre la
confiance l'uralité le contact au grand
texte alors sans nul doute qu'à Poitier
proclamé capital de l'éducation à maint
reprise par l'ancien ministre
Jean-Michel Blanquer ces annonces elles
ont été entendues et surtout leurs
concrétisations seront attendu DEP pied
terme quelques syndicats nous ont d'ors
et déjà appelé et Delphine Emmanuel
Macron a également beaucoup parlé de
santé hier c'est un sujet que vous
suivez particulièrement dans votre
journal d'ailleurs il y a un an il était
dans la Vienne Emmanuel Macron ouais on
s'est dit que c'était l'occasion de
faire un petit retour en arrière un pas
de côté en décembre 2022 le président de
la République s'était déplacé à
fontaine- lecte c'est une commune dans
la Vienne qui est proche de de Poitier
sa mission à cette occasion là c'était
de lancer le tout premier Conseil
national de la refondation consacré à la
santé alors un an après on s'est demandé
quels sont les projets concrets qui ont
été mis en place dans la Vienne grâce à
ces échanges avec les élus de terrain et
finalement on s'est rendu compte que pas
mal d'initiatives ont vu le jour où se
sont concrétisé dont une qui change la
vie au quotidien de bientôt se épad du
territoire de la Vienne soit environ 600
résidents et cette initiative c'est la
mise en place d'une infirmière de nuit
car oui en épade vous ne le savez
peut-être pas la nuit il n'y a qu'une
aide soignante et un veilleur de nuit
mais il y a pas d'infirmière donc
désormais c'est l'infirmière Marion
Lecor qui est officie et que nous sommes
allés rencontrer hier c'était tout chaud
et c'est à lire aujourd'hui dans
l'édition du jour et Marion elle elle
explique que ça lui change aussi la vie
d'être infirmière de nuit en épad elle
confie que la nuit elle a plus de temps
avec les résidents et elle a donc
retrouvé du sens à son travail un vrai
enjeu pour les infirmières aujourd'hui à
l'issue de cette expérimentation
l'agence régional de la santé a fait un
bilan et c'est celui de la baisse du
nombre de résidents qui vont aux
urgences pendant la nuit qui est été
mise à jour c'est environ 25 % des
résidents qui vont moins aux urgences et
ce n'est certainement pas anodin pour
des patients qui sont âgés et qui sont
fragiles et que tout changement bouscule
comme quoi on le lit aujourd'hui dans
notre journal une initiative politique
ça peut parfois améliorer concrètement
la qualité de vie des citoyens les plus
fragiles et ça fait quand même du bien
de dire ça parfois merci dalphine merci
beaucoup la Une de La Nouvelle
République c'est l'un des sujets abordés
également par Emmanuel Macron hier c'est
la question de la natalité viennent les
naissances en chute libre c'est à la Une
de votre journal merci merci beaucoup
define Blanchard d'avoir été avec nous
on va évidemment continuer de parler de
cette conférence de presse d'Emmanuel
Macron on parlera de la question de
l'école dans quelques instants avec vous
Steve et de ses annonces en matière
d'école mais on va voir le reste des
annonces du chef de l'État tout de suite
avec Coren rano
Emmanuel Macron a centré son
intervention sur la jeunesse égrainant
des mesures sur l'école et l'instruction
il a indiqué vouloir avec l'aide
d'expert déterminer le bon usage des
écrans pour les enfants le président de
la République veut s'attaquer à la
baisse de la natalité le congé parental
va devenir un congé de naissance de 6
mois qui sera mieux rémunéré en
parallèle le président entend s'attaquer
à l'infertilité
l'infertilité masculine comme féminine a
beaucoup progressé ces dernières années
et fait souffrir beaucoup de couples un
grand plan de lutte contre ce fléo sera
engagé pour permettre justement ce
réarmement démographique côté santé la
lutte contre les déserts minicau est
mise en avant il s'est dit opposé à la
pour l'installation des médecins mais
est favorable à la régularisation des
médecins étrangers mais aussi en
assumant sur le terrain de régulariser
nombre de médecins étrangers qui
tiennent parfois à bout de bras nos
services de soins Emmanuel Macron c'est
aussi montré favorable au doublement de
la franchise médicale elle va passer de
50 centimes à 1 € par cette mesure il
entend responsabiliser et dégager des
fonds pour la prévention à
l'international Emmanuel Macron a
annoncé qu'il se rendrait février en
Ukraine la France va livrer 40 nouveaux
missiles de longue portée et des
centaines de bombes pour résister aux
attaques russes le plus grand risque à
mes yeux et la guerre d'agression russe
en
Ukraine nous ne pouvons pas laisser la
Russie gagner et nous ne devons pas le
faire car alors la sécurité même de
l'Europe et de tout le voisinage russe
serait remise en cause le chef de l'État
a aussi annoncé l'organisation d'un
hommage le 7 février aux victimes de
l'attaque PERP par le Hamas le 7 octobre
41 français sont morts dans cette
attaque en
Israël c'est pas fau on va évidemment
parler de cette conférence de presse
avec vous Nicolas est-ce qu'il a réussi
l'exercice le chef de l'État pour vous
en tout cas il a atteint son objectif
qui était d'avoir une posture et une
expression qui s'adresse à un électorat
vraiment bien ciblé celui qui qui vise
pour les élections européennes qui est
un électorat on va dire conservateur de
droite je dirais même pour être encore
plus prè si c'est c'est c'est c'est de
l'analyse par rapport au mots on va
peut-être en parler là les sémantiques
la sémantique utilisée les thématique
utilisé c'est je dirais il tente de
cibler l'électorat qui est parti de LR
vers reconquête avec des thématiques sur
l'école et puis des des des des relants
un peu de de nostalgie dans dans ce qui
peut exprimer autour des de l'éducation
et donc il a impositionnement tactique
qui euh qui qui qui espère pouvoir
contrecarrer le le le le le scénario de
désastreux annoncé d'une défaite parce
que ça sera analisé comme ça au européen
10 points derrière le rassemblement
national pour l'instant dans les
sondages il a réussi pour vous cet
exercice c un exercice qui visait à
relancer je vois déjà votre sourire la
réponse à la question j'ai
envie j'ai envie de me mettre à votre
place et vous poser la question vous
avez appris quelque chose hier soir non
mais sérieusement vous avez appris
quelque chose
direelok j'exagère sa très bien je peux
avoir un côté un peu parfois où
j'exagère mais enfin moi j'ai pas le
sentiment d'avoir appris énormément de
choses et surtout c'est assez euh c'est
assez étonnant parce que quelques jours
auparavant il disait à ses
parlementaires et à ses ministres soyez
des révolutionnaires cess d'être des
gestionnaires bon moi j'ai vu un
gestionnaire gestionnaire hier j'aurais
aimé être présent je n'y étais pas et
lui poser la question mais qu'est-ce
qu'il y a de révolutionnaire dans ce que
vous avez à nous proposer il y a des
Français qui n'arrivent pas à se loger
il y a des Français qui n'arrivent pas à
vivre correctement tout en travaillant
euh euh toute la journée donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a un problème c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu comme proposition
révolutionnaire pour changer
radicalement la vie des français on vit
dans un moment où les Français je pense
on ralebolle de la politique parce que
ellees dégrad leurs conditions de vie
ils attendent de leurs représentants et
notamment du président de la République
qu'il fassent des annonces qui consacr
sur plusieurs chaînes de télévision hier
soir 2hures de son temps 2 heur de temps
au français pour ceux qui ont regardé
qu' qui qu'ils espèrent qu'on leur
annonce quelque chose qui va changer la
donne y compris sur des sur les sujets
qui sont des sujets essentiels comme
celui de l'énergie les 10 %
d'augmentation la question lui a été
posée il a renvoyé à son chef de
gouvernement sans vouloir tout en
laissant entendre que bon possiblement
il y aurait quand même une augmentation
donc la question du pouvoir d'achat ou
du pouvoir vivre des Français elle est
pas réglée hier c'est quand même la la
préoccupation principale je je moi
j'aime bien quand il revient quand il va
chercher quand il pue ses mots dans les
dans les dans les ressources
révolutionnaires Emmanuel Macron il a
qucé comme ça il a écrit un livre qui
s'appelait révolution mais il y a rien
de révolutionnaire on est là un
gestionnaire qui va plus loin dans les
réformes sur les réformes libérales les
réformes de contrôle des chômeurs il a
dit qu'il irait plus loin encore cette
année sur le contrôle des des des des
chômeurs bon voilà moi j'ai j'ai rien
appris hier et je je crains avoir perdu
mon temps comme beaucoup de Français
vous y étiez vous Nicolas est-ce que
vous attendiez à autre chose non parce
que on avait compris déjà depuis le la
nomination du gouvernement qu'il avait
une une tonalité plus à droite qui était
donné par Emmanuel Macron et donc on on
attendait à ce qu'il y ait peut-être
voilà une explication de de méthodes
mais il est pas rentré dans les
explications de méthode il est surtout
ni dans l'idéologie il a surtout fait du
du concret du pragmatique et puis on
l'évoque sur l'école des questions assez
symboliques et il avait à cœur de de de
peut-être de sortir du débat politique
d'ailleurs les questions politiques
l'élis avait demandé à ce qu'ell soit
posée dans un second temps et qu'on
commence par poser des questions
relatives à ce qui venait d'annoncer et
automatique qu' avait mise sur la table
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a beaucoup
parlé d'école et aussi de de santé et là
il a été dans un registre on a retrouvé
l'Emmanuel Macron de 2017 très concret
très pragmatique très rationnel
maîtrisant à la perfection tous les
dossiers étant capable d'en parler
longuement donc il y a des réponses
quand même qui qui duraiit un certain
temps mais
montrant au français au français qu'il
regarder ben qu'il avait une pleine
connaissance et une pleine conscience
dans ces domaines là de de ce qu'
pouvait de ce qu'il fallait faire donc
de ce point de vue-là on a quand même eu
un président de la République alors
certains disent c'est pas présidentiel
ça prend pas assez de hauteur mais en
tout cas il montre à l'opinion que il
connaît bien les choses et que il a bien
identifié les les leviers d'action donc
sur ce planl il est il est resté dans
dans dans un domaine ou dans
une posture où il est plutôt je trouve à
son avantage après les questions
politiques elles l'ont pas
particulièrement misise dans la
difficulté parce qu'il il a répondu
rapidement il a quand il a été relancé
il a évacué et donc il voulait pas faire
vraiment de politique hier il voulait
surtout être dans la posture enfin de la
politique ça reste de la politique mais
il voulait dans la posture et et et
répondre et donner une image à un
certain type d'électorat
aviser en visant les les élections
européennes ouais on va parler des
europénes puisil notamment par du
rassemblement national mais d'abord l'un
des grands thèmes c'était l'école vous
le disiez Steve c'est un peu le ministre
de l'éducation qui s'est exprimé hier
soir oui beaucoup de ministres de
l'éducation en ce moment il y a la
ministre évidemment Oda Castera et puis
il a Gabriel Atal qui a dit vouloir
remporter la cause de l'école avec lui à
matigan et puis donc Emmanuel Macron qui
hier a fait de l'école l'élément presque
central de sa conférence de presse
écoutez je veux qu'on mette fin à cette
France du ceci n'est pas pour moi ou
ceci n'est pas pour toi de ces enfants
qui continuent à se dire que parce
qu'ils viennent deel de ce quartier
qu'ils ont ce nom l'accès à telle
formation ou tel diplôme l'accès à la
culture ne leur est pas du n'est pas un
droit pour eux l'ordre va avec le
progrès l'autorité va avec
l'émancipation ind disociable et donc
oui la réponse à cela c'est l'école
l'école l'école quelle école l'école
l'école pour demain gros mortiau de
l'intervention présidentiel qui parle de
réarmement de l'école il y a eu
plusieurs annonces qui en fait n'en sont
pas réell puisque certaines étaient déjà
connues notamment la révision des
programmes le doublement des heures
d'éducation civique à partir de la 5e
qui passera de 30 minutes à 1 heure par
semaine à partir du mois de septembre ou
encore l'expérimentation de la tenue
unique à l'école ça avait été annoncé
par gabrielal en décembre le président
l'a confirmé hier
écoutez la tenue unique qui a donné lieu
à tant de débats ces derniers mois dans
notre pays et qui efface les inégalités
entre les familles en même temps qu'elle
crée les conditions du respect sera
expérimenté dès cette année dans une
centaine
d'établissements tous volontaires
quelques nouveautés s oui trois
nouveautés l'instauration d'une
cérémonie de remise des diplômes au
collège et au lycée le renforcement des
cours d'histoire de l'art c'est un
enseignement qui est aujourd'hui
optionnel Emmanuel Macron et le
gouvernement devront encore préciser
devront encore nous dire s'ils
souhaitent les rendre obligatoires et
puis enfin le théâtre les cours ne
seront plus optionnels le chef de l'État
souhaite les rendre obligatoires pour
tout le monde petite erreur Steve moi je
crois avoir compris que depuis 2016 la
cérémonie des diplômes a été généralisé
dans C communes certaines mairie mais
c'est Naj valobelkassem qui lorsqu'elle
était ministre de l'éducation nationale
l'a généralisé dans lesétablissements
scolaires dès 2016 bah du coup on va
vous faire réagir sur cesy vous êes
lancer écoutez moi je troué ça bien moi
je je trouve ça très bien j'en sais rien
en tout cas la phrase qui consiste à
dire parce que les élèves parce que les
jeunes regardent des séries où on voit
des jeunes avec des costumes des
uniformes et qui trouvent ça très bien
je veux dire si si il faut s'appuyer sur
des séries euh pour pouvoir mener des
politiques et fixer un câ ça me paraît
un peu un peu hasardeux bon mais je
trouve quand même que sur la question de
l'éducation l'éducation nationale il a
fait des annonces qui évidemment vont
dans le bon sens moi je trouve que
l'idée de généraliser la question de la
pratique du théâtre dans les
établissements scolaires c'est une bonne
chose y compris pour la confiance en soi
y compris pour la connaissance des
textes euh des classiques ou pas
d'ailleurs je trouve que c'est une bonne
chose mais ce que se disent les
enseignants et les parents d'élèves
aujourd'hui c'est comment il le fait
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on manque
déjà d'enseignants qui va s'occuper de
ces enseignements là euh que ce soit les
enseignements sportifs vu qu'il veulent
il veut aussi accentuer le sport à
l'école mais aussi la culture à l'école
c'est qui qui sont les enseignants qui
vont gérer seses ses ses enseignements
l'éducation renforcée aussi et c'est
plutôt une bonne chose alors il appelle
ça l'instruction civique euh moi je je
trouve que c'est c'est évidemment une
bonne chose qui va le faire ce sont les
enseignants d'histoire ce sont les
enseignants de français ce sont des
nouveaux enseignants qui interviennent
dans les classes ce sont des
associations et je je veux dire le
problème principal et il l'a dit
plusieurs fois il a pas répondu à ce
problème principal c'est l'absence
d'enseignants euh en nombre suffisant
dans les établissements scolaires il a
pas annoncé des créations de postes
supplémentaires il a pas annoncé des
créations de de de de de disciplines
supplémentairire qui allait être
enseigné à l'école c'est c'est cette
confusion là en fait là où il y a déjà
une une grande interrogation des
personnels de l'Éducation nationale et
des parents d'élèves la communauté
éducative dans son ensemble sur le
manque d'effectif dans l'établissement
scolaire il n'y a pas répondu donc il va
chercher des discipline et c'est plutôt
une bonne chose mais le problème majeur
c'est que les élèves aujourd'hui ou
l'enseignement public souff re d'un
manque de personnel oui il y a répondu
pierre il il a il a établi le constat
des heures qui manquaient dans dans dans
le primaire notamment et des des des
heures de d'absence de profs qui sont
absents pas très longtemps sur des
courtes durées pour les il a dit on a
ouvert le capot avant on comptait que
les absences longes durées maintenant on
compte les courtes exactement pour
lesquels il y avit pas d'information
jusqu'ici et la réponse du gouvernement
ça a été elle est déjà faite d'augmenter
les rémunérations pour pouvoir attirer
davantage de monde au concours parce que
les postes budgétairement ils sont
ouverts le problème c'est qu'ils sont
pas pourvu parce qu'il y a pas assez de
personnes d'étudiantes d'étudiants qui
vont se se porter candidate et candidat
pour devenir prof et donc la réponse
face à ça c'est peut-être qu'il a
d'autres aménagements des du du temps de
travail je ne sais pas mais sur le plan
de la rémunération le gouvernement a bel
et bien fait quelque chose alors
peut-être qu'il devrait aller encore
plus loin mais la rémunération je suis
d'accord avec vous pas de mais la la
difficulté principale est de revaloriser
le métier dans toutes ces dimensions de
de sorte qu'il y ait des vocations qui
puissent s'exprimer et remplir les
classes sur l'école CIV il a évidemment
été interrogé sur la polémique Amélie
oua casterra oui la nouvelle ministre de
l'Éducation toujours englué dans une
polémique depuis ses propos sur la
scolarisation de ses enfants dans le
privé elle a visité hier l'école
publique parisienne d'où elle avait
retiré son fils elle y est allée pour
présenter ses excuses des excuses plutôt
bienvenues selon Emmanuel Macron écoutz
la ministre a eu un propos public qui a
été maladroit elle s'en est excusé elle
a bien fait
je vais vous dire j'ai plutôt de
l'indulgence parce qu'il m'est arrivé
d'avoir des propos au tout début de mes
responsabilités politiques qui avait
blessé tout particulièrement des femmes
dans une entreprise du Grand Ouest et et
quand on blesse surtout sans s'en rendre
compte on a raison de s'excuser voir si
ces propos d'Emmanuel Macron fa vont
suffire pour faire passer la pilule
auprès des syndicats d'enseignant je
vois pierre sourire en tout cas c'est
une ministre
confortée ministre fragilisée pourquoi
mais parce que c'est pas le sujet je
veux bien qu'on on va nous faire croire
aujourd'hui qu'il y a eu un conflit
ouvert qui a été qui est lié à celui de
l'école publique contre l'école laïque
personne ne reproche à Amélie ou di
casterra d'avoir scolarisé ses enfants
dans une école privée il y en a
quelques-uns qui le font mais c'est pas
ça le sujet le sujet aujourd'hui c'est
le rapport qui a été rendu et publique
par Mediapart hier et je m'étonne
d'ailleurs que mes confrères de
meddiapart n'ai pas eu été invité à
poser leur questions ou en tout cas
n''est pas été autorisé à poser leur
question parce que le fond de l'affaire
c'est que quand même depuis plusieurs
mois il y a un rapport qui est sur le
bureau du ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui s'appelle Gabriel à
l'époque des faits et ce rapport est
passé aux oubliettes ou en tout cas n'a
jamais été rendu publique et Amélie ouia
casterra nous explique aujourd'hui
qu'elle n'a pas ce rapport entre ses
mains il se trouve que bizarrement
mediap part là il l'a révélé hier et le
rapport est absolument accablant sur à
la fois le caractère un peu séparatiste
de cette école qui fait œuvre enfin qui
use d'un nombre de de de de de principes
totalement inconforme à nos valeurs
républicaines donc c'est c'est quand
même des écoles qui sont sous contrat
qui doivent répondre à des des à des un
cah des charges républicain et et et là
personne ne pose la question à Emmanuel
Macron qui est quand même le cœur du
sujet quand même ce rapport il y a
effectivement la question de Stanislas
mais au-delà ce qui a été aussi reproché
à émilieactera c'est de relancer la
guerre public privée d'avoir blessé les
enseignants a pas eu besoin de ce
rapport pour se fragilisé toute seule
dans une séquence de communication où
elle a enchaîné les erreurs qui a
particulièrement irrité à Matignon et et
aujourd'hui elle est une ministre de
l'éducation nationaleah qui reste
fragilisée malgré l'appui que lui a
apporté hier Emmanuel Macron on a
entendu son indulgence moi aussi j'ai
fait des erreurs elle s'est excusé euh
on on on imagine bien que ces excuses
elles sont insuffisantes pour l'ensemble
du corps enseignant qui euh les
syndicats l'expriment depuis plusieurs
jours espère qu'elle puisse faire des
excluses générales et pas uniquement à
l'établissement concerné et puis on on
dit dans l'entourage de Gabriel Atal
qu'il faut maintenant qu'elle donne des
signes et des même des signes importants
euh d'intérêt et et qui soit
politiquement porteur de sens à l'égard
du monde enseignant mais mais pas
seulement parce que au-delà de des
enseignants il y a les parents d'élèves
et il y a les enfants et et là ben ctera
elle a devant elle une feuille blanche
qui va falloir remplir rapidement avec
un démarrage très mauvais alors vous le
disiez Nicolas il y a une partie plus
politique dans cette cette conférence de
presse du chef de l'État Emmanuel Macron
qui en a profité pour s'en prendre
vivement au rassemblement national on
l'écoute
que le rassemblement national comme
toutes les extrêmes droites en Europe
c'est surtout et avant tout le pays de
l'appauvrissement collectif c'est le
parti du mensonge et ça continue de
l'être c'est le parti qui a le programme
qu' a complètement piqué à l'extrême
gauche c'est le parti qui continue de
vous expliquer des choses impossibles
sur le plan économique et social pour
affaiblir il a lancé la campagne des
européennes de la majorité hier avec
cette tirade Nicolas oui bien sûr a deux
moments pendant cette conférence de
presse où il s'est un peu agité le chef
de l'État il a ce moment pour parler du
rassemblementional et puis un moment sur
la la loi immigration mais finalement
c'était la même chose c'est le le la
même question de fond qui lui est posé
de de son attitude face à à l'extrême
droite là il s'est donc animé et on a
compris que euh implicitement passait le
message à son gouvernement lui demandant
d'aller au combat et d'avoir les mots
justes et forts face à à l'extrême
droite c'est le danger principal pour
Emmanuel Macron mais la question là
encore lui a été posée hier c'est euh à
l'issue de ce qu kenade de laisser la la
place à l'Élisée à Marine Le Pen c'est
la tendance que donneent tous les
sondages d'opinion donc ce point de vuel
il est extrêmement fragiliser le le chef
de l'État et donc il est obligé de de de
bah de sortir de de ses retranchements
et puis de de d'avoir des mots plus
forts et et plus dur à l'égard de Marine
Le Pen et Jordan bardellaa sachant que
hier dans les arguments il il est allé
moi je trouve c'était un peu court il y
avait d'autres arguments qu' aurait pu
qu'il aurait pu développer mais on sent
quand même cette cette difficulté que
l'ensemble de de du discours la la
tonalité les annonces même s'il y a des
choses qui étaient déjà connues en tout
cas la façon de les présenter euh ça
vise directement à essayer d'aller
chercher des électeurs qui sont tentés
par le ressemblement national pour
affaiblir le RN aux élections
européennes cette droitisation c'est ce
côté plus conservateur aujourd'hui
d'Emmanuel Macron il est il est un peu
contre nature parce qu'il est pas comme
ça idéologiquement le chef de l'État il
est beaucoup plus libéral beaucoup plus
progressiste et là il est contraint euh
par des des des questions de de tactique
mais aussi par la situation de l'opinion
il est contraint d'aller toujours plus
sur sa droite et jusqu'à quel point il
peut faire cet exercice et cette avoir
cette plasticité idéologique là hier
soir on a quand même touché la limite
parce que est encore au-delà ça serait
pour lui une forme de de de reniment je
pense ouais ça ça peut marcher ça sa
stratégie de dire il faut aller sur le
terrain du RN et et et combattre ce qui
donne envie aux gens de voter RN pour
affaiblir le RN on a le sentiment en
tout cas que Emmanuel Macron est dès
lors qu'il a les questions de de de de
l'extrême droite du rassemblement
national est emporté par la question les
deux moments où il s'est un peu emporté
hier ça a été la première question qui
lu a été posée sur est-ce qu'il sera
comptable est-ce qu'il se sent comptable
ou héritier de de de de de l'extrême
progression ascension de l'extrême
droite en France et la deuxième question
c'était une concert du monde qui lui
pose la question sur le La loi asile et
immigration où elle fait le
rapprochement entre le caractère ou en
tout cas le oui le caractère lié à la
préférence nationale qui est inscrit
dans ce texte et euh est-ce que ça
marche pas un peu sur les plat de bandes
de l'extrême droite il a pas du tout
aimé la question et d'ailleurs
étonnamment il a continué de dire que ce
texte n'était pas encore signé il était
celui qui était censé signer le décret
d'application ou la promulgation et du
Conseil constitutionnel et que voilà il
attend la la la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel ce qui quand même
continue de renforcer cette idée que
quand même ils ont fait passer un texte
dont ils savent très bien qu' a un
certain nombre de de dispositions qui
sont inconformes avec notre Constitution
mais que c'est pas grave c'est la
Constitution qui va régler le problème
politique moi je trouve que le problème
Emmanuel Macron l'a un peu balayé d'un
revernement en disant vous regardez
c'est pas que la France c'est partout en
Europe enfin fa qu' un moment donné
certes il faut aussi se rendre compte
quelles sont les politiques qui sont
menées en Europe qui sont sans doute la
raison pour laquelle les Français ont de
plusentés par un vote de Marine Le Pen
et puis j'ajoute une dernière chose il
dit qu'il a fait ce qu'il fallait faire
notamment sur les questions d'emploi
parce qu'il a l'air de dire que c'est
les questions d'emploi qui vont régler
le problème sauf que si aujourd'hui on
s'enfonce dans une précarisation une
popérisation de l'emploi avec des
millions de travailleurs pauvres comme
on est en train d'en construire je ne
suis pas sûr que ça favorise le vote
rationnel raisonnable d'une d'une d'une
frangeche de l'électorat plus on va
continuer à créer des générations de
travailleurs pauvres plus Marine Le Pen
va sans doute en en tirer profit je vais
être d'accord sur ce point avec
formablez tout ça bien j'ai une petite
question de fin quand même tout arrive
et c'est vrai que hier le grand absent
de de cette conférence de presse c'était
le travail finalement et et surtout la
conjoncture du travail on sait que la la
croissance a ralenti il y a une hausse
du chômage donc il y a des difficultés
qui sont potentiellement devant le
gouvernement et sur ce planl la gestion
conjoncturelle il y a pas eu un mot du
du chef de l'État alors il y a l'annonce
d'une nouvelle d'une étape de de réforme
du marché du travail qui irait dans le
même sens que l'étape précédente on peut
s'interroger de savoir s'il y a pas une
petite un petit dénis de réalité en ce
moment au sein de l'exécutif sur le fait
que la croissance ralentie il y a
peut-être des choses à faire dernière
question puisque il a été interrogé
évidemment sur Rachid adati qui est la
surprise du gouvernement Rachid adati
qui annonce ce matin sa candidature à la
mairie de Paris moins d'une semaine
après sa nomination au ministère de de
la culture c'est un un timing qui est
opportun c'est un timing qui est
étonnant parce qu'on est quand même
longtemps avant l'élection à Paris et
donc c'est une façon de enfin c'est une
histoire politique qui est qui va un peu
vite quand même un peu vite en besogne
parce qu'il peutv se passer énormément
de choses d'ici là et puis le le
l'électorat parisien c'est un électorat
on l'a vu qui est assez volatile euh qui
a pu voter Macron en 2017 puis revoter à
gauche en 2022 euh donc le le voilà ce
qui ce qui interroge beaucoup c'est ce
calendrier politique vis-à-vis de de
Paris après rachidti on l'a dit on le
répète
c'est on appelle ça une prise de guerre
en tout cas c'est c'est une personnalité
qui pour Emmanuel Macron vient combler
un manque c'est la capacité à aller au
combat et avoir des formules et puis à à
à à aller attaquer les oppositions et ça
lui faisait défaut jusqu'ici pas ass de
monde dans son gouvernement capable de
faire ça un dernier mot surchti pi ils
sont tous en campagne Gabriel non que je
dire mais gabrielal il il est en
campagne pour peut-être la mériie de
Paris peut-être devenir président de la
République rachidti on le sait tous elle
a une ambition pour Paris elle veut
créer la revanche avec
anidalgo sur 2000 en
2026 ça ne fait c'est plutôt ENF c'est
vrai que ça fait c'est toujours étonnant
quand même le lendemain de sa nomination
d'ex Ava en campagne pour per Paris
c'est toujours un peu étonnant mais au
moins le mérite de la clarté et de la
franchise pour moins que ça je me
souviens quand même qu'une ancienne
ministre de la Santé cert dans un
contexte particulier qui était celui du
covid on lui a demandé quand même de
quitter son poste de ministre parce que
être compagne c'est un boulot à plein
temps peut-être que la culture ne mérite
pas d'être à plein temps on va continuer
à parler de cette conférence de presse
d'Emmanuel Macron qui fait la une de vos
quotidiens régionaux ce
[Musique]
matin Steve à la une de la presse rionel
ce matin c'est Emmanuel Macron ouiel
Emmanuel Macron en maesté dans la presse
quotidienne ce matin Emmanuel Macron qui
a donné un cours d'éducation civique
selon les DNA le général Macron a
annoncé le réarmement de la France selon
La Dépêche du Midi pour wouest France il
a lancé l'acte 2 du quinquena Midi Libre
parle quant à lui du tourbillon Emmanuel
Macron sur le fond certains ils vont un
virage un virage à droite pour corce
matin c'est un basculement sur la rive
droite du macronisme écrit le journal
son discours était taxé sur l'éducation
et l'ordre avec des annonces rappelant
la France du général de GA cert le en
même temps philosophique est toujours là
mais clairement le chef de l'État a
procédé à un réajustement du curseur
selon corp ce matin dans la presse
également le stress pour les élèves de
terminal oui c'est aujourd'hui que la
plateforme parcourssu ouvre ses portes
c'est à la unee du Courrier de l'Ouest
qui nous dit bonjour l'angoiss les
étudiants doivent fixer leur choix
inscrire leur vœux postbac sur cette
plateforme avant la le milieu du mois de
mars il formule 10 vœux maximum après
l'analyse de leur dossier par les
enseignants ils recevront une réponse
pour chacun de leurs vœux le 30 mai
prochain bonjour l'angoisse
effectivement journée difficile dans le
nord de la France courier Picard demande
si les habitants sont parés pour la
tempête Irène qui touche la Picardie à
partir d'aujourd'hui il faut s'attendre
à des pluies vertglaçantes suivie de de
chutes de neige des cumules qui pourrai
atteindre 7 à 10 cm par endroit en
Picardie et le sud du P decadé les
conditions de circulation seront très
compliquées aujourd'hui dans la région
quand on l'attaque la cathédrale de rond
contre-attaque oui c'est une affaire qui
remonte à la fin du 19e siiècle qui trou
sa place en Une de Paris-Normandie des
vitrux de la cathédrale notred-dame de
rouan avait été volé à l'époque il se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans des musées
américains une association a déposé de
plainte pour RESSEL alors que ses vitr
ont été mis au mis aux enchères il y a
quelques années par la prestigieuse
maison de vente SOS Beis ils avaient
auparavant circuler sous le manteau et
traverser l'Atlantique le parcours
surprenant de ces vitrux est à lire dans
Paris-Normandie ce matin merci Steve à
lire dans Politi les M oui chass aller
par la porte il reviennent par la
fenêtre on croyait l'affaire terminée et
bien non c'est reparti le débat sur les
OGM revient au Parlement européen et ça
pourrait aussi très rapidement revenir
dans nos assiettes lire dans Politis
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait lire dans La
Tribune dimanche Nicolas c'est la
question rituelle du
mercredi et j'ai une réponse ah vous
allez pouvoir en lire plus dans la
tribune dimanche parce que nous
augmentons la pagination nous avons de
nouvelles rubriques ce weekend ah on
peut savoir sur quoi ou non suspense
c'est tous les mercredis c'est un
suspense merci beaucoup Nicola pr merci
pierrejacquem d'avoir été avec nous
merci Steve prochain rendez-vous à 15h
la première séance de question
d'actualité au Gouvernement de Gabri
Premier ministre au Sénat ce sera suivre
sur notre Anne et puis à 18has public
très bonne journée à
demain